hi everyone
this is professor mdos science and today
i want to talk about the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
is one of the most famous results of
quantum mechanics it has captivated the
imagination of generations of scientists
and non-scientists alike
however the principle is very frequently
misunderstood and misrepresented in this
video we'll discuss what the uncertainty
principle
really tells us about quantum states
there is a companion video that provides
a mathematical proof of the principle so
i also encourage you to check it out
let's go before we can understand
uncertainty principles in quantum
mechanics we need a quick refresher
about some of the important ingredients
making up these uncertainty principles
let's consider a system in state psi
this state contains all the information
about our quantum system
however when we want to extract this
information we need to write down this
state in some basis
or representation the usual way in which
we build the basis is by considering a
hermitian operator
say a and hermitian operators allow us
to describe physical quantities so you
can think of a as for example the
position or the energy of a particle
the key equation to consider is the
eigenvalue equation of a
where as usual lambda n are the
eigenvalues and
u n the eigenstates this eigen states
from a basis of state space
so we can expand this state psi in this
basis
and the expansion coefficient c are the
bracket between u n and psi
these expansion coefficients provide a
representation of the state psi
in the u basis of eigenstates of a
but in general there is nothing special
about operator a
we can define a second hermitian
operator b that corresponds to some
other physical property
we can also write the eigenvalue
equation of operator b
now the eigenvalues are mu m and the
eigenstates are vm
the vm eigenstate also form a basis of
state space so we can also expand the
same state
psi in this new basis and now the
expansion coefficients d
are the brackets between vm and psi
these expansion coefficients provide a
representation of the state psi
in the v basis of eigenstate of b
so here we're always working with the
same state psi of the system
these two different representations are
simply two different ways of writing the
same state
we could solve any quantum problem in
terms of either and the physics wouldn't
change
moving forward i'll assume that you're
comfortable with these concepts but if
they are new to you then you should
first check out the video on
representations
what we'll learn in this video is that
the heisenberg uncertainty principle is
a mathematical relation
between the c coefficients and the d
coefficients that we can use to write
the same quantum state psi
let's continue with some refreshers we
consider again
the expansion of state psi in the u
basis of eigenstate of some operator a
to help in our discussion we're now
going to represent the state psi in the
u basis in a pictorial manner
consider a pair of axes on the
horizontal axis we're going to place the
eigenvalues of the operator a
and on the vertical axis we're going to
place the absolute value squared of cn
we use the absolute value squared of cn
rather than cn directly because we know
from the videos on measurements that
this square is related to the
probability
of getting a particular eigenvalue when
we measure property a
so let's pick some values of these
c-squared coefficients starting with c1
squared for the first eigenvalue
and then similarly for the other
eigenvalues
here i'm just making them up but in
reality we would determine them from
this expression
as we discussed in the videos on
measurements we can interpret a diagram
like this as a probability distribution
what's important for this video is that
this diagram provides a pictorial way
of characterizing a state psi of the
system when we write it in the basis
determined by the operator a
and we actually need a final refresher
before we can discuss uncertainty
principles
which is the idea of a root mean square
deviation
we again start with the state psi in the
u basis with the usual expansion
coefficient c
let's draw a pair of axes again
with the corresponding labels
i again draw our pictorial
representation of the state psi
and this time i am conveniently drawing
it with a peak around some particular
eigenvalue lambda m
the root mean square deviation is a
quantity that allows us to characterize
probability distribution such as this
one
the root mean square deviation of a in
state psi is called delta a
and it is defined as the square root of
the expectation value
of sigma a squared where sigma a is
equal to a
minus the expectation value of a
delta a can also be rewritten like this
so what does the root mean square
deviation tell us mathematically sigma a
is measuring the distance
from the mean of the distribution so
delta a is a measure of the width of
this distribution
again i will assume that you're
comfortable with these concepts if they
sound new to you
then you can find all the details in the
video and expectation values linked in
the description
we're now finally ready to introduce the
heisenberg uncertainty principle
the setup is as following we have a
state psi
and two operators the first is a with
its eigenvalue
equation and the second is b with its
own eigenvalue equation
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
tells us that the root mean square
deviation of a
multiplied by the root mean square
deviation of b is larger than or equal
to
one-half times the absolute value of the
expectation value
of the commutator of a and b
okay so this is a bit of a mouthful but
in the rest of the video we'll explore
what the principle means from a
conceptual point of view
for the mathematical proof of this
result you should check out the
companion video on the heisenberg
council in the principle
which you can find linked in the
description
a quick aside before you continue if you
have encountered the heisenberg concerns
in the principle before
it'll probably have been in terms of a
particular example where the observables
are position and momentum
and then it takes this form but the
relation is actually general for any two
observables a and b
so we'll focus on the most general form
today
so what does the heisenberg uncertainty
principle mean
let's start with the case when a and b
don't commute
this means that the right hand side here
is larger than zero
so that the product of delta a and delta
b is strictly larger than zero
we first consider our system in some
state psi
working without pictorial representation
again we now need to consider
two pairs of axes
in the first we're going to represent
the state psi in the basis of eigenstate
of a
and remember that in this case the
eigenvalues are labeled by lambda
and the expansion coefficients by c
in the second we represent the state in
terms of the eigen states of b
whose eigenvalues are mu and the
corresponding expansion coefficients are
d
starting with the a basis imagine that
for this particular state psi
the distribution is centered around a
particular eigenvalue
lambda n if we consider the same state
psi
in terms of the eigenstate of b we get
these other distributions centered
about some eigenvalue mu m
these two distributions represent the
same state psi
in two different bases what the
uncertainty principle tells us
is that they are not completely
independent if we consider the root mean
square deviation of the first one
and the root mean square deviation of
the second one
then by the heisenberg conservative
principle their product must be larger
than
some lower bound and as a and b don't
commute in this example
this lower bound is a positive number
to see this more clearly imagine that we
have a second state psi
prime we also consider our two pairs of
axes
starting with the bases associated with
a we have the eigenvalues lambda
and now the expansion coefficients are c
prime
and for the bases associated with b we
have
mu and d prime
for this new state psi prime imagine
that the representation in the a basis
is also centered around lambda n but it
is much narrower than for the state psi
we had earlier
this means that delta a for this new
state psi prime is very small
as the heisenberg uncertainty principle
still needs to be obeyed
if delta a is very small then unless
delta b is relatively large
their product will not be above the
lower bound set by their commutator
this means that having a very small
delta a forces us to have a relatively
broad distribution when we write
psi prime in terms of the b basis
and we need this to ensure that delta b
is large enough to obey the uncertainty
principle
overall what this means is that the
representations of a given state in two
different bases given by two
non-commuting operators
are inversely related the narrower the
distribution is for one operator
the wider it needs to be for the other
and vice versa
all of these to ensure that the product
of their root mean square deviations is
larger
than the lower bounds by the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
so as claimed at the very beginning of
the video the uncertainty
principle allows us to relate the c and
the d
expansion coefficients of a given state
the case when a and b commute is not so
interesting
in this case the heisenberg uncertainty
principle still holds
but all it says now is that delta a
times delta b
must be larger or equal to zero so in
this case
even if we make delta a very small we're
not forced to make delta b large because
their product can be as small as we want
in particular there are states with
delta a and delta b arbitrarily small
at the same time if you remember from
the video on compatible observables this
actually makes sense
because two operators that commute can
be simultaneously diagonalized
which means that we can have states that
are eigenstates of both operators at the
same time
so in this case for operator a
and simultaneously for operator b
where the common eigenstates are labeled
by the corresponding eigenvalues
we also know that the root mean square
deviation calculated for an eigenstate
of the operator vanishes
so this means that if the state of our
system is one of the common eigenstates
of a and b
then delta a is zero and delta b
is also zero this result is
still consistent with the heisenberg
uncertainty principle because the lower
bound of the product of delta a and
delta b
is zero for commuting observables
we can also reverse the argument if a
and b don't commute
then you can view the heisenberg
constantly principle as a restatement
of the fact that the two operators
cannot be diagonalized simultaneously
because that would imply that we could
have both delta a and delta b
be zero but it is impossible if the
lower bound of the uncertainty principle
isn't zero
so now that we understand what the
uncertainty principle means
a question that you may have at this
point is why do we call this relation an
uncertainty principle the name
uncertainty principle
is in fact rather unfortunate because it
can be and it has been
the source of misrepresentation and
misunderstanding of what the principle
really means
if we work again with our state psi and
we start with the basis of eigenstates
of a
and let's consider again our pictorial
representation
i have again chosen a distribution that
is strongly peaked near particular
eigenvalue lambda n
what this means is that the expansion of
the state psi in the u basis
is dominated by the u n term associated
with eigenvalue lambda n
which in turn means that c n is
approximately equal to one
while all other expansion coefficients
are close to zero
from the videos on measurements we know
that the probability of obtaining a
particular
eigenvalue as the outcome of measuring a
in state psi
is given by the absolute value squared
of the corresponding c
expansion coefficient in this example we
would have that p
lambda n is close to 1 because cn is the
dominant term in the expansion and is
therefore close to 1 itself
in turn this means that if we were to
measure a in state psi
then we would almost certainly get
lambda n as the outcome of the
measurement
so in this particular state psi we can
predict with high confidence the result
of a quantum measurement
before we perform it when this happens
we sometimes say that the property a
has a definite value in state psi
now let's repeat the analysis for the
same state psi
but now in the basis of eigenstate of a
different operator b
whose corresponding pictorial
representation is based on these axes
as we discussed a moment ago if a and b
don't commute
then the uncertainty principle forces
the pictorial representation of
psi in this second case to be very broad
and it is to ensure that delta b is
large enough to obey the uncertainty
principle
in this case the expansion of psi
contains many nonzero terms
so all the dm are of comparable size
and this in turn means that all the p mu
m are also comparable
so if we think about measurements again
this means that if we were to measure
property b
in state psi then because the different
probabilities are all comparable
we cannot predict at all what the result
of that one measurement of b
will be it could give any value
so given this discussion where does the
word uncertainty
come in in the first case where we work
in the eigen basis of operator a
we can predict what the result of the
measurement will be before we do the
measurement
because this probability is almost 1.
this means that we can say that property
a
has almost a definite value and this
means that there is very little
uncertainty
on the value of a even before we do the
measurement
by contrast in the case of property b we
have no idea what the outcome of the
measurement will be
before we perform it and that's because
all probabilities are comparable
so now we can say that there is a high
degree of uncertainty
in the value of property b in state psi
so it is from this use of the word
uncertainty that we get to the name
uncertainty principle for this relation
up here
having said this it is very important
that we don't misunderstand the word
uncertainty
it does not mean that we don't know
something about our system because we
haven't been able to characterize it
fully
because of some limitation of our
measurement apparatus
we do know absolutely everything there
is to know about the quantum system
and it is all described by this state
psi
what the uncertainty principle does is
it relates different ways of
representing the same state psi
before we finish it is worth relating
our discussion to the more familiar
uncertainty principle between position
and momentum operators these operators
obey the canonical commutation relation
and substituting it into the general
form up here we get this
which in turn gives the usual expression
that delta x delta p
is larger than or equal to one-half
h-bar
position and momentum are continuous
variables so when we write the state psi
in the position basis we have this
expression in terms of an integral
rather than a sum
in this case we typically call the
expansion coefficients psi of x
and they are given by the usual bracket
this psi of x is of course what we call
the wave function
in quantum mechanics we have a similar
expansion in the momentum
where basis representation is now in
terms of so-called momentum wave
functions
psi bar of p
so what does the uncertainty principle
look like in this case
let's draw the axis for the position
operator
now the eigenvalues are the continuous
variable x
and the vertical axis is the absolute
value of the wave function squared
and we also have the corresponding setup
for the momentum operator
what the uncertainty principle tells us
is that if we have a very narrow wave
function
in the position representation then the
corresponding wave function in the
momentum representation
will be very broad of course the
opposite holds
if we have a wave function that is very
narrow in the momentum representation
and it will be very broad in the
position representation
all of these is to ensure that the
product delta x delta p
is larger than a half h bar
more generally we know from the video
and wave functions that these two
representations are related by a fourier
transform
if you are familiar with fourier
transforms you will now immediately see
that the fourier transform already
encodes the uncertainty principle
if you have a very narrow function and
calculate its fourier transform
then you end up with a very broad
function and vice versa
perfectly consistent with the
uncertainty principle
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
allows us to relate representations of
quantum states written down in terms of
the eigenstates of different operators
and it becomes particularly exciting
when these two operators don't commute
although the most famous example
corresponds to the uncertainty between
position and momentum
we've learned that the principle is much
more general and it relates any two
operators
and remember that in this video we've
only discussed what the uncertainty
principle tells us
but we haven't proven that it is true
for the full mathematical derivation of
the principle
don't forget to check out the companion
video and as always
if you like the video please subscribe